kylie jenner offers a rare glimpse of
her and travis scott's son
i think it's so good oh it's a good one
all right taking to instagram on
saturday the beauty mogul shares an
intimate snapshot
not only do we see her baby boy's feet
but big sister stormi makes a cameo too
the proud mama writes quote i made these
little feet i'm having fun
this comes after kylie gave her fans
another quick look at the newborn in
april
she shares a pick of travis holding
their yet to be named son
and with a couple of fashion trend
setters for parents it's no surprise the
little ones got some swag he's rocking
black and red sneakers and blue jeans
kylie has yet to share a full photo of
her son after announcing in march his
name will no longer be wolf which she
recently opened up to e.t about
why not wolf
and
what is the name wolf was never on our
list okay it just was actually something
chloe suggested and i like don't do this
i liked the name i don't think anything
i still like
i love it i love it i like wolf i just
wasn't him so it wasn't against anything
to do with the name it just wasn't him
you know totally i get that so
sometimes you have to meet
the baby i mean i didn't name any of my
kids for ten days two weeks and i
contemplated changing names like it's
the hardest thing in the world to name a
child and they give you what they say
there's a deadline the birth certificate
within you know ten days or something
and with it being a few months since
welcoming the baby boy she and travis
may be close to making a decision
so do we have a name no we have some
really strong options but we haven't
officially changed we have some
placeholders so before i officially
change it i just want to be sure you're
seeing that little personality
perhaps kylie is waiting for a tv debut
to show the young one's face and reveal
his name
as her pregnancy has been playing out
across the kardashians
my whole life is so public my pregnancy
is really public this time
to have something between just travis
and i feels really special i'm gonna get
cheese fries
and a single cheeseburger and you've got
two people to feed
i know
while kylie and travis might be keeping
the little one to themselves for now
mom and dad recently stepped out with
stormy
[Applause]
the couple made it a family night while
attending the 2022 billboard music
awards trev are you enjoying your family
night out
kylie are you enjoying mom and dad
nights out hi stormy
take a look at this happy family
[Music]